all right the democrat's war against
fossil fuel is part of its war against
gas powered cars and the war against gas
powered cars is a war on freedom of
movement and the biggest beneficiary is
drum roll please the Chinese Communist
Party well again because of its
dominance in the EV battery Market China
can lower its costs indefinitely really
and just outc compete us every time and
rather than do the logical thing which
is harness the power of America's oil
and gas Industries let them go Biden
would rather us and then is not
worried at all about giving China the
upper hand but of course Biden couldn't
do any of this without his help that he
desperately needs from his friends in
Corporate America and they're just as
eager to sell the country out as Biden
is last night this was astonishing the
US China Business Council it already
sounds bad held its annual very glitzy
Gala in the swamp and its chairman Mark
Casper is also the CEO of thermofisher
scientific he gave everyone a pat on the
back for the Great China cow toow and
along with thermal Fisher the American
companies represented here this evening
have been at the Forefront of China's
modernization the benefits of that
progress are eminently clear and have
made a profound positive impact on the
Chinese people and our goal is to
further strengthen this relationship to
the benefit of both countries and
Society overall that's funny that's
really funny tell that to the millions
of people who lost their jobs over the
last 20 years Mark I'm surprised he
didn't do that in Mandarin well he just
one of the many CEOs though on this
Council Boeing Nike JP Morgan Chase
caola others all sit on the China
Business Council board of directors and
they had no problem at all giving
China's ambassador to the United States
a platform to scold any of us who dare
object to the ccp's infiltration of our
country some people though have been
hyping up so-called China threat
slapping new sanctions and forcing a
China invested agriculture company with
over 50 years of presence in the United
States to sell its
Farmland all these stand in stark
contrast to the statements by the US
side that is ready to keep growing
economic and trade relations with
China but surely the guest of honor
Janet Yellen pushed back on all this
right yeah right she used the
opportunity to attack Trump for actually
having stood up to China the Trump
administration had failed to make
investments at home while also
neglecting relationships with our
partners and allies it damaged our
Global standing and meant significant
missed economic opportunities for
American firms and workers the Biden
Administration has
corrected in a sense she's right the
Biden Administration has course
corrected away from Trump's policies of
putting America First and back to the
old regime of giving China a blank check
and an open border to our country hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else